I was the digital director for President
Obama's 2012 campaign for us and
different companies structure digital
and technology and and all those fields
a little differently for us digital men
everything user-facing everything that
you could actually touch and read and
watch and play with online so we didn't
do the back-end infrastructure and most
of the coding but we did we had all the
writers the designers video folks people
doing content and creative and creative
strategy when it came to communication I
mean we had a sort of a three word
strategy that was really quite simple
which is don't be lame and it's funny
you know when you talk to a corporate
marketers when you talk to people who've
been doing PR for a long time they will
themselves acknowledge not being lame
has never really been their mo because
they're sort of well versed in risk
mitigation that well versed in how not
to annoy stakeholders or create problems
but they've never had to actually deal
with consumers who can click away as
soon as they don't like what they are
what they're seeing and making sure that
what they're serving those consumers
with is something that they like
obviously that that content has to have
a purpose it has to have a message but
the consumer doesn't even get to the
point of absorbing the message if first
and foremost they think well this is
dull and so the most important thing we
try to do in a came to communication was
just be interesting I think a great
example is came from around let's see
would have been October of 2012 sort or
the very end of the campaign at that
point we were arguing over tax policy a
lot and our argument was the governor
Romney's tax plan didn't add up it was a
from our point of view a giveaway to
millionaires and billionaires it wasn't
paid for and he never really explained
how it wouldn't explode the deficit and
so we wanted to get at that but we
didn't want to do just a policy white
paper or a statement from an economist
or something of that nature you know
those things have their place I mean we
did that sort of stuff all the time but
you know when it came to actually
getting people to understand what our
point of view was and trying to create a
sort of a fun non lame experience for
people around you know this most arcane
of topics tax policy you know we wanted
to you know we want to create something
different what we wind up creating was a
site called Romney tax plan calm it was
very kind of the Romney folks not to
steal that domain before we got to it
and it was a big thing that said you
know here's Romney's tax plan and it was
a
antik button in the center of the screen
that said get the details and as you
hovered over to get the details button
to get the details button danced away
from you and no matter where you put
your mouse you just could not click on
this button so it was kind of fun and it
was it was a hit beyond even what we had
had hoped it would be I mean it was it
had 1.5 million and Facebook Likes
within a day it got tweeted seventy
thousand times it's the only time in my
personal a career that my own mom has
sent me something that I was involved in
creating saying have you seen this and I
had to say yeah my money yeah I don't
think you understand you know what my
job is yeah I've seen it but you know
the amazing thing about it was that a
million and a half people actually read
The Associated blog post in which we
actually went through the math in a more
serious way if you clicked I think it
was like eight seconds if you if you
tried to click for the first eight
seconds you couldn't and the button
would dance around from you after that
if you clicked it would actually bring
you through to our blog post explaining
the math and we looked at bounce rate we
looked at time on site every sort of
indicator we had suggested that the
people who got to this post actually
read it and so it's this kind of amazing
thing where by creating something that
made our point but did it in a way that
was sort of fun and funny and shareable
and different it wasn't just taking a
press release and putting it online in
the most pretty way we could it wasn't
even an infographic that maybe could
have been interactive because it was
online but really could have existed in
a newspaper 20 years ago I mean it was a
completely different kind of content it
was a Content that just simply couldn't
have existed before the internet a
really creative i think approach to a
policy issue that people don't like
talking about and it obviously resonated
with people i would not have thought
that we could get a million and half
people to read a blog post on tax policy
you